what can I'm a very like - I'm Lucas I
work here in booking so very happy to
see you all here in my own territory so
to speak and today I wanted to talk
about diagnosing statistical machine
learning models and you know I've been
trying to put up this presentation for a
while
and I thought that the best way to put
it is with examples so I prepared two
examples today so let's get started with
the first one which is about bicycles so
if you were expecting to see some hotels
or remember in Amsterdam bicycles always
have priority
ask the owner of this car here otherwise
okay so that is to study a system about
bicycles rental and this is a system
that allows you to rent bicycles and we
want to understand the demand so the
data we have is about how many bicycles
are rented per hour we have information
about the weather in particular we have
temperature the speed of the wind the
humidity the overall water situation
situation like cloudy sunny rainy and we
have some information about the time a
weekday is a holiday and all the obvious
features again expect from from a date
like the month the Sison stuff like that
this is two years data so it's about
17,000 observations not big not small
and the purpose is explanatory so that
he has to understand what which of these
variables impact the demand of bicycles
and we also want to know to quantify
this influence of this variables in the
demand of bicycles and the model is a
linear model and algorithm is ordinary
least-squares implemented these issues
and starts models cycle learn pandas the
usual suspects and let's see what
happens if we just throw this data to
OLS in starts models and we get the
first undesired behavior which is a lot
of non significant coefficients so
is a linear model and what you see here
in the x-axis are all the features I'm
using only few are labeled of course and
and the y-axis you see the p-value for a
t-test for correlation of the input
whatever with the output variable so
essentially what this means does is that
the model fails to find significant
correlation between the input variables
and the target value which in this case
in this case is the amount of bicycles
rented per hour related to this large
p-values of course we see very large
standard errors so here in the x-axis
you can see again the feature names and
on the y-axis you can see the relative
standard error that is the standard
error divided by the actual estimated
coefficient and you can see goes all the
ways from a little bit less than 110
percent to 60 percent that is the level
of uncertainty we have about the
coefficients of these variables is
really high and this is very bad because
then it means we cannot really stylish
relationship between these variables and
that's exactly the purpose of our model
now there are several reasons why this
may happen and and this is in a sense
two symptoms of a very common issue in
machine learning of statistical modeling
which is large variance when estimating
coefficients if I I didn't put the chart
but if I change the sample you know and
the columns and the rows we can see how
the coefficients actually actually
change a lot and that means well they
did pretty much this is the literal
definition of overfitting the values
that we estimate that the ordinal arms
are very much coupled with the data that
we used to estimate them so one reason
for large variance is a bad relationship
between the amount of observations that
we have and the amount of parameters
don't want to estimate now in this case
we have only 40 variables so this means
the linear model will need 41 parameters
including the intercept and as I said
you have 17 thousands observations so if
you want to stimulate 1741 parameters
with 17,000 observations is just fine
should be okay so we can definitely disc
our the issue of not having enough
sample size now what's another pathology
that can produce these symptoms when the
responder is a quite common which is
known as a multicollinearity and the
idea of multicollinearity is that if we
take input variables at least one can be
predicted by looking at the others so in
this case for example had we have the
temperature so maybe we can predict
temperature as a linear combination of
humidity and the speed of the wind if
that that is the case and that means
that there is redundancy in the velocity
variation to predict or to estimate a
month and this redundancy completely you
know prevents us from making conclusions
about how these variables are related
because I versus like ordinary
least-squares and pretty much every
linear algorithm even SVM with a linear
kernel will try to explain the variance
in the target variable in this case
hourly demand of bicycles by assigning
coefficients to the input variables to
independent variables but but if there
is redundancy in the independent
variables then these coefficients can be
assigned arbitrarily and this arbitrary
assignment of coefficients actually
comes from the fact that there is
redundancy and that makes these values
which is the thing that we really care
about really depending on the data that
we are using and that's why we see large
variance we change the data and the
coefficients change so these are nice
hypotheses but we need to make sure that
this is the case in our model is there
or there isn't multicollinearity there
are many ways to to check for
multicollinearity most statistical
packages give very good estimates and
hypothesis tests of meticulous starts
models has a thing called the condition
number which is quite a tongue-twister
I'm not going to go into details and the
main reason why I think it's not very
important is because this test only tell
you that there is multi color but
doesn't help they don't help you at all
so understand were Disko linearity or
multi cooling that is coming from
and give you information about how to
fix it so what I use usually in the past
actually not so much these days and I
propose is to use what I call a
clustered correlation plot and the idea
of the cluster the correlation plot is
quite simple it's just take the
correlation matrix of your input
variables take the absolute value we
don't care about the direction of the
correlation we only care whether there
is or not correlation and then apply a
clustering algorithm to this matrix and
the options were clustering are the
variables and for this is recommended to
use and assume a clustering algorithm
that doesn't require the amount of
clusters beforehand because of course we
have no idea and the very nice one that
they successfully use in the past is
affinity propagation back in the days I
was using my own implementation today
scikit-learn has a very nice
implementation of affinity propagation
so you can just throw the correlation
matrix to the implementation of cycle
learn and get the results once we have
the clusters we can plot the correlation
matrix but you know sorted by cluster
assignment so in the rows we're going to
put first all the variables that are
signing to the same cluster then the
valves that are assign it to the second
cluster and so on so if we have a
perfect system where there is no
redundancy at all between the variables
not correlation at all we would see
something like this so the diagonal is
absolutely red this is because there is
always absolute correlation between
everybody will and itself and this
sounds something it's good to check and
then after they are not we see blue in
this case deep blue a very dark blue
because it's zero because there's no
correlation whatsoever with between any
other variable now if we apply this
technique to the bicycle status set this
is what we see now we can see if several
things first of all there's blue all
over the place that's a good thing there
is information in pretty much every
variable but we also see of course the
diagonal red which is very important but
we see red orange green yellow
everywhere off to they're gonna and that
means there might be some issues with
multicollinearity
we also see the clusters of the
algorithm phone and for example you have
holiday weekday and working day that
seems to be a pretty good cluster our
humidity and wind speed is another
cluster maybe it doesn't make that much
sense but then we find for example the
third cluster it's a cloudy sunny snowy
and rainy and they are all together in
the same cluster so let's dig deeper
into that one so what we see here is
that cloudy is highly correlated to
sunny and cloudy is slightly correlated
to snowy but we also see that rainy is
not really correlated to any other of
the variables but there are filter
propagation algorithm still manages to
capture these four variables in the same
cluster and this is telling us that
there is a problem with these four
variables now what is the problem well
this one is quite obvious we have four
categories and every hour there is
exactly one category so there's only one
world situation per hour and I use one
hot encoding using four binary variables
so if you do that then that means the
sum of all these binary variables will
always be one and that means I can
always predict one of the binary
variables as the sum of the others or
one minus the sum of the others and this
is exactly the definition of perfect
multicollinearity I can perfectly say
look it's not cloudy it's not sunny it's
not snowy it's got a bit rainy it's
cloudy then it cannot be rainy
I can always predict one word about
looking at the others and this
introduces this pathology known as
perfect multicollinearity so this I got
using pandas get dummies in this case if
we want to look some code and you
specify the categorical feature that you
want to one hot and cold and by default
pandas won't drop any variable or
anything so the way to fix it is very
simple we ask pandas to drop the first
level in this case I think it will drop
sunny because it's the first add its
observed in the data set this will fix
the problem but once we do this we need
to be careful about the way we interpret
the coefficients because once we drop
one categorical level then the
coefficients are estimates for all the
other categories
we with respect to the one with dropped
so supposed we dropped cloudy here and
then we observed that sunny gets ten
more bicycle rentals that is sunny gives
you ten more bicycle rentals with
respect to cloudy days and this is a
very tricky and it's very important to
take care of and when we have small
categories small amount of categories
like this it's easy but if you have
plenty like cities like countries and
and whatnot or hotel IDs then the
interpretation of the coefficients gets
much more tricky okay so of course this
is a problem for every categorical
variable in the set so I fix it for all
of them and you may think that will fix
the whole problem but if I repeat this p
value on all variables we we see that we
improved a lot but not really done we're
far from from one there are still many
variables that so large P values and
that means we still are failing at
making conclusions which is in the end
the purpose of our model so if we repeat
the process here's the second cluster
the correlation plot and here we can see
that there are less clusters there is
less red that means by dropping the
first level of every category we improve
clearly and the first cluster seems to
be fine but the second cluster seems
there is a very dark red spot and then
that might mean that there is something
wrong over so let's dig deeper there
first of all the cluster is quite
consistent it's a summer temperature a
temperature September August July June
of every these are variables that make
sense to be clustered together now it's
important to note that as we go fixing
this multicolored in the pollen the
clustering will the clusters will lose
sense right because they the clustering
tries to find correlated things and yes
if we remove them then the cluster will
lose cohesion so what we see here is
clear temperature is very highly
correlated with this special limbs
suspiciously named a temp and by this
moment I decided to go and read the
documentation of the data set and as it
turns out the temperature is the
temperature what you would expect an 8
is the feeling temperature and of course
it's to whatever's are highly correlated
are absolutely redundant so it's quite a
no-brainer that we need to drop one of
them now let me come in just really
quick that this is not always the case
sometimes it's really difficult to
choose a variable to drop and there are
techniques that we can use to avoid that
for example taking the ratio of the
variables is a trick that works very
well if someone is interested can take
it off I have examples but I couldn't
find it in this particular data set it's
not just to want to make the point that
removing variables is not always the
best solution okay maybe we're done well
not really we reproduce again repeat
again the cluster correlation plot and
we see again that there are some
yellow-greenish clusters off the
diagonal and it's funny to see that
Rainey is alone there its own cluster
I'm not sure what that means but so if
we if we look at the by the way this is
Washington this is not a Salam I got you
Alan so if we look at these clusters
that are showing some not so healthy
structure we're going to look at them
all together because they are all
related so in the first cluster we see
summer is correlated with summer almost
a temp that's good and July and
September then we also see that fall is
correlated to October and November and
we also see a spring is slightly cooler
to the June and a little more with May
in April so what this is telling us is
very obvious actually it's not shocking
that the season is correlated with the
month but this shows actually a nice
ability of this cluster the correlation
plot of picking up correlations between
multiple variables and this correlation
is tricky because it's a hierarchical
structure if we know the month of course
we can tell the season but if we know
the season we don't definitely not know
the month we just get some information
and this means that this tool is really
helpful to find more complex
multicollinearity structures or multi
collinear fact
in the data set and again in this case
it's very easy to solve we can just drop
one of the variables and in this case I
chose to drop system because there are
only 12 months and we have a lot of data
to estimate properly a coefficient for
every month if we would get for example
and this we see a lot in booking.com
something like country and city we have
hundreds of countries and hundreds
thousands of cities so this introduces
multicollinearity and the thing is
estimating a coefficient for every
possible city with significant tests is
difficult but doing it for country is
much reasonable thing to do
so sometimes it's worth to stick with
small amount of significant results than
a large amount of insignificant results
it's a trade-off between predictive
power and you know explained ability of
them of the model I think you need to
speed up yeah root case the cost for
this is hierarchical features tend to be
correlated and the treatment in this
case is remove system we do this and
finally we get to some cluster the
correlation plot that looks more like
the ideal one we saw at the beginning we
see there is blue all over the place of
course there are some correlations
between some variances is fine in this
case we see the temperature is
correlated with June July November would
extreme month or temperature go stream
and also with the humidity with sunny
would cloudy yeah I don't know difficult
to interpret okay so we get here and we
can say that the multi clarity problem
is solved if you check starts models as
we do this we see that this condition
number tells where there is multi
clarity or not disappears so that's most
give you an alert and when you get here
the alert goes off that's a good sign
and now we can also see again the
p-values chart and we can see that there
are only three variables for which there
is an a confidence a significant result
every other variable gives you a
significant result and this means we can
start now interpreting the model
properly and make conclusions just for
completeness nothing really shocking in
this data set is not that
thing but it looks like fall is the
system with the highest demand I would
expect that it was a spring or something
but it turns out is this fall
now humidity and wind have a negative
impact on on cycling that's expected but
what I wasn't expecting this humidities
has a war's impact than than wind and
finally it looks like these people is
business
bikers because the demand drops on
holidays and I wasn't sure about this
when I said well I got the sign wrong
and then I go and read the documentation
even more closely and so it seems this
is a data set about people that share
bicycles to go to the office so yes of
course on holidays people don't go to
the office some people I'm at the office
so to wrap up this example I really need
to speed up a very interesting point I
believe in this chart you can see the
evolution of the trusted correlation
plot when exposed to different scenarios
perfect multicollinearity redundant
variables hierarchical variables and not
collinearity at all the percentage shows
the amount of the percentage of
variables that show a significant
coefficient and in the chart you can see
the R squared which is some sort of you
know estimation of the quality of the
model from a predictive point of view so
we can see how as soon as we fix the
perfect multicollinearity the our scores
improve a lot from really bad to decent
from zero six two zero eight and and and
then it doesn't move at all whereas the
number of redundant numbers of
significant variables good also steadily
of course it is a diminishing return but
it keeps on growing so the idea that the
message I want to send with this chart
is that depending on the purpose of your
model you may want to care more or less
about this pathology and for example if
you really care about predictive power
well you should only probably care about
perfect multicollinearity really severe
multi-core enter problems but maybe not
so much about the milder
multicollinearity issues now if you
really want to explain your modern fine
correlations it is important to focus
really hard on this problem and the
thing this is a general this is true for
every pathology depending on the purpose
of your model the pathology I need to
focus to diagnose will be different okay
that's it for bicycles and now let's
check this one business versus leisure
the idea here is to study a little bit
about our domain in booking.com and we
want to understand the travel purpose of
our visitors and for this we have data
about users that tell us whether why
where they travel for business or
leisure and we want to build a model
that can successfully discriminate this
two type of travelers because we want to
give them a personalized experience it's
completely different website if you go
for business on leisure but in this case
it's completely different scenario than
the previous one here I like to use this
reference to a paper by Google which is
called pixel repetition a view from the
trenches where they analyze the usage of
models in real environment and that's
the case for this model that we have we
want to put it in production and make
predictions for every visitor and the
data were that is exposed to this model
changes all the time so the view from
the trenches looks like this incomplete
information delayed information and
dynamic information incomplete
information means we want to predict for
every visitor in the website buddy but
it will only get labels for people that
book and tell us where they travel for
business or leisure the land information
means then even for those that book and
tell us they will only tell us two or
even 15 days later so we have a delayed
in the feedback of the prediction and
finally dynamic information refers to
the fact that the label distribution
changes in depending on the season the
proportion of business versus leisure
changes and changes dramatically and
even quite in subsurface depth function
it's not smooth at all and finally also
the the feature space changes the amount
of people that travel from from one part
of the world or the other changes the
distribution changes or the anticipation
or the how many days you stay in a hotel
it changes and finally one that is very
very difficult to
to work with the stream co-star we get
new visitors new users new hotels were
growing really fast we have new
destinations every day and how do we
train ones that can support this level
of of madness of the data where they are
actually deployed so the question is how
can we develop diagnosing tool that
helped us to understand whether a
classifier whether your model is doing
what it's supposed to do any contest
will have incomplete delayed and dynamic
information so I propose to use this
idea of response distribution analysis
and it's amazingly simple and amazingly
powerful at least in my opinion and the
idea is just just build a histogram of
the probabilities of the model that
model outputs for every request so
imagine we have a hundred thousand
visitors in an hour and for every
visitor we're going to make a prediction
so the model will output the probability
that gives us 100 hundred thousand
probabilities a hundred thousand numbers
between zero and one so we just build a
histogram of these numbers and the
structure of the system will tell us a
lot about what's happening with the
model when exposed to the particular
context so this is an example of this
model so in the x-axis you can see the
output of the classifier that's the
probability of the positive class given
the feature of course it could be on the
future depending on where your mode is
generative or discriminative that really
doesn't matter and in the y-axis you see
the normalized frequency of that
particular output so you can see this
chart of the probability of the
probability of an object being of a
visitor being leisure and this is it
this is the tool we see in in grey the
PDF in in orange we see the cumulative
distribution function that of course
will go all the way to 1 and you know in
blue you see a recommended threshold
that is some sort of threshold
probability to decide whether the
visitor is business or leisure now let's
take a look at different patterns that
we find all the time that I want to
analyze how they help us to understand
what's happening with the model
the first one actually is what I call an
omniscient model and this is a model
that is not only always right but he
knows that he's always right and what
this means is it will never give you a
probability it will always give you one
or zero and it's always the correct
answer so if we have such a model which
is absolutely ideal it doesn't exist
then if we apply this response
distribution historama then it would
look like this two peaks 1 at 0 1 at 1
and the height of the peak the peaks
will be related to the distribution of
the class this is a 50/50 model because
of course of course I had a call to this
I never saw this and we're never gonna
see this but we expect to see this plus
noise we do expect to see some sort of
mixture of two beta distribution or
mixture of two chi-square distributions
and we expect to have the two modes one
in different extremes so this is a
confused model this is an air pattern
this is a model that is completely
failing at discriminating two classes
you can see it always predicts pretty
much the most common predictions
0:44 which is very close to some
regularized prior so the model is
absolutely failing and using the
training data to learn to discriminate
into two classes so the main traits of
this kind of models are that they have
one single mode it's central and there
is not not stable point no stable point
means that if you look at this system as
a mountain and you drop a ball
everywhere in the mountain the drop will
just go away you won't stabilize
anywhere it doesn't matter what you drop
the ball which is fall and go and you
see how I this is important a second and
the root cause that we always see or
suspect about we can not really prove
this it's a day's high base error that
is that your training set is not really
deterministic with respect to the label
that is you supposed to use only two
features the country of the user and the
day of the week well all you can learn
is the distribution of all the labels
whether it's business of leisure you can
not really
determind so the solution for this is of
course to add features and not to create
new features from the ones you have
that's not gonna help at all
but two other new features to go and
look for more features outside what you
already have if we do that we might end
up with an over conservative model which
is a model that again fails completely
discriminate but in this case is a
different you know for for different
reasons in this case the model really
doesn't achieve to output probabilities
in this case bigger than 0 52 or sounds
like that it's very unlikely and I want
to highlight that you may have a very
good model offline in your computer
running very well you see 0 85 but you
are probably looking at this model with
the bias data set because you can only
train them all for this examples for
which you have labels when we put it in
production we need to understand what
the model does when even when we don't
have labels and that was that's why it's
very common that we see very good models
offline and I would put in production
and they they don't work so in this case
the over conservative model will have a
sparse support that means not all the
possibilities are present it's not as
smooth at all because it's very shaky
it's like more like a nervous model
there are extreme modes so there is one
mode the most frequent value is very
close to 0 or 1 in this case closer to 0
and there are multiple stable points
whatever use up the ball the ball will
get stuck the main the potential cost
arrive seen for this is the sparse model
so suppose I use a feature like Hotel ID
if you don't have a weight for every
possible Hotel ID then you will see this
because then when when a new is not a
new hot lady but it's just that your
model didn't assign a weight to one
particular hot lady for example because
you're using very strong regularization
but when you put in production that hot
ready will appear and since you don't
have any weight and this happens for
many hotels you will see this type of
structures and the way to fix it is to
make sure that you have something to say
about every feature value that the the
model of
serves in when actually serving
predictions in that case elastic net
regularization is much more advisable
for for machine learning people here
moving on we start to do better now so
if we fix this sparsity model now we get
a much better model we can see we can
start to see some sort of discriminative
power in the center you see the blue
line is actually separating the support
is quite wide so it goes all the way
from my screen to the other is very
smooth but there is an extreme value in
general this is a legislation in general
we don't want a model to be that certain
ever there's no point
on being that certain about the
prediction in this case we see that
there is an extreme mode so the most
common value is one and it's well just
two extreme is the only value that
actually you know picks up pretty much
the whole distribution now the reason
for this one are plenty and this is the
most common problem we see code start is
is again there so if you assign if you
have a new training set the very not
popular hotel
you might assign a big weight to it but
you won't see it in training set because
this blends into the million of hottest
we have and you won't cause any problems
now that particular hotel suddenly
becomes really popular and it has a very
big weight and therefore the inner
product in the legitimation blows up and
the sigmoid function goes to one and
this is what we see here so that's one
of the reasons for this program the
second reason is a liar's this is very
common also you get some outliers that
you didn't see at all in training set
and then they might have very large
values and then again this the inner
product blows up and the signal goes to
one and they actually most common one is
integration issues you develop a model
for example using how many you know the
price in uterus of a hotel but when you
put it in production someone sends the
price in Colombian pesos so this will
use completely different scale and again
you will multiply this number by a
weight and again this inner product
blows up and you get and you know the
Sigma will go to one so this type of
structure really help us to understand
what what's what's going on one one
thing that I'm not showing here is that
we can dig into every bar right so we
can go and click ok who are these guys
that are actually telling us always one
you can go and look at the value of the
features and really make some more
handcrafted analysis and find really
insightful insightful things and finally
we get to a maybe good model so you can
see this model you can see clearly two
modes two pretty Peaks is very smooth
there is a very clear threshold that we
can use to discriminate with one class
and the other and there is a stable
point that means if we put the ball
somewhere in the distribution it will
fall exactly where the blue line is and
that's probably the best threshold to
use to make a hard decision whether the
user is business or leisure and what the
reason why say maybe is because this
model could be completely wrong could be
absolutely zero accuracy so that means
that this tool only help us to
understand what type of price might be
happening
it will never tell you that the model is
good you can only tell you that the ball
model is bad and well this is what I
just said
and this is a design model a couple of
weeks later and you can see how it
really changed quite a bit
and the distribution changed and we can
see a new mall
growing close to the recommended
threshold and this means that when there
are changes in the underlying
distribution of the thing we want to
predict this tool will caption this is
very useful for us to you know when we
deploy model it works everything is fine
and after two months then this model can
be completely wrong
and this helps us to understand this
early enough and to capture issues when
we have to when we can still fix them
this is too good to be true I think I
saw this one on April 1st no but really
this can this actually very useful you
will see this actually a lot and this is
usually due to leakage you're probably
leaking the label as a feature and we
this leakage is noisy it's not perfectly
kitsch the model won't say 1 or 0 it
will still give probabilities but it
will be just too nice and then you
should definitely not trust this ones
and finally it looks like robots travel
for leisure so he had this robot attack
a couple of weeks ago and the model
thinks that robots travel for leisure
and and well yeah and yeah it took us a
while to feel that this one and the
robots are quite systematic didn't have
a lot of variance so that helped that
helped a lot so if you're developing
robots make sure you change the
variables and yeah just one more look at
the from the from the trenches like as I
like to say these respond distribution
analysis helped us a lot in this
incomplete delayed and dynamic
information scenario and the idea is
that incomplete information is address
with global feedback we can get we can
get feedback from every example we make
a prediction not only those for which we
have a label which is very important
unfortunately mookie mods most people
don't book so we cannot rely on that to
actually and understand what our models
are doing the light information again is
addressed by the fact that this is
immediate as long as you start making
prediction predictions you can build a
system and start understanding where the
mall is doing bad or not and finally
dynamic information well this is very
responsive feedback that you get because
it changes it's very sensitive to
changes in the distribution and the line
distribution of the context in which the
model is deployed it is a thing to still
work with for feature space it's not
really that sensitive to feature space
Changez but yeah we need to work to
improve that too yeah some limitations
of course it only works for scoring
classifiers if you have a decision tree
this won't help you because the decision
tree doesn't give you score doesn't give
you I mean a decision tree in order
random forest I know it's not very
common but it's one case in which you
cannot use this this tool and it only
detects red flags it points in the
directions of pathologies it won't tell
you exactly what to do it won't really
tell you hey do you have our freedom
problem fix it or decrease lambda no you
will only help you to say hey there's
something fishy there is a very night
thing very nice technique from the
object-oriented programming community
and they call it the bad smells and
there are even papers about this and
they they relook code and they detect
bad smells well I think this is a very
good metaphor for this tool it's a tool
that helps you to to get and pick up bad
smells but then once you you get did you
get this batsman you need to go look
further to actually test check that
there is a problem and finally
regression nothing to say about it this
one helped and ranking is a very
interesting problem we have an extension
for multi-class for small amount of
classes but if you go to many many
classes this doesn't really help ok some
closing remarks to more slice industrial
remarks so this is the view from the
industry we saw this sequence of
diagnosing tool helping us to move
towards a better model and we saw the
same with this other tool they are all
helping us to improve our model
continuously so the idea is that model
diagnosis can be seen as an iterative
process especially in the industry maybe
not so much in the academia well you can
treat every problem as a unique problem
but in the industry we really get this
pipeline of problems one behind the
other so looking at modern nursing as as
an iterative process is very useful this
process will be it is driven by
diagnosing tools and this diagnosing
tools are what point
in the direction of what to do next so I
have this what should I do to focus on
our fitting should I focus on getting
more features should I change the
algorithm because it's just too simple
and yeah like I explained the first
example the ultimate goal is to achieve
a purpose that your model is set up for
so explanatory models will require one
type of treatment predictive modeling
will require a different type of
treatment and even in predictive
modeling estimating values is not the
same as discriminating or classifying
versus regression is very important to
understand what are we actually trying
to achieve our model because this is
what will drive the type of techniques
that we use and yeah to finish if we can
come up with systematic diagnosis
process then we can build up a beautiful
continuous improvement process and this
is again very very relevant for the
industry where we got one model behind
the other and we want to be successful
with all of them or at least the
majority that's all I have thank you all
and I'm happy to take questions comments